in September of 2016 the European Space
Agency Rosetta probe landed on comet 67p
and what a lot of people don't know is
that there's a rosetta disk on board and
it's really kind of cool to think that
out there in space is this archive of
humanity the disk itself has thousands
of pages microscopically formed into the
surface of a very thin sheet of nickel
and the nickel is very resistant to
temperature it can withstand high heat
it can withstand changes in environment
and it can potentially last and be
readable for thousands of years
in 2008 we released the first version of
our rosetta disk and we made just a few
copies of these and they're in archives
and special collections around the world
but it's long than our goal to create a
version that we can make lots of copies
of and the idea of having lots of copies
is that that helps keep the information
safe because of some of the copies over
time get destroyed then chances are
better that some of them will remain
working with a company called nano
Rosetta we've developed a smaller
version of the rules any disk it has the
same technology that is it's got mica
formed pages in the surface of the
nickel disk but it's about the size of a
coin it has a thousand pages of
information on it the main text that we
chose for all of these different
languages was the preamble of the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
and we have that for about three hundred
and thirty languages and then we have
the same set of vocabulary words about
200 of them
in over 600 languages so the text and
the vocabulary provide that same content
in many different languages and that
could be the temple said a stone key to
deciphering languages in the future and
besides that we have some very unique
content to the long now foundation one
of these is the full text of the clock
of alum now by Steve Laird we also have
some updated clock diagrams as well I'm
a linguist and I've studied human
languages for a long time I care very
much about the number of languages in
the world because I think that each
language represents a unique world view
and it's our hope that everyone who has
one of these wearable discs can join us
in our effort to build this archive of
humanity and to move this knowledge into
the future